[Musique]
bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on va parler
du yoga book de lenovo
si vous avez regardé ma première vidéo
de unboxing et de prise en main sur le
yoga bout de lenovo
effectivement je vous expliquais que
j'ai eu la chance d'être sélectionné par
les nouveaux pour faire partie de leurs
50 testeurs officiels
pour tester cette tablette aujourd'hui
on va la regarder sous un angle un petit
peu différent là yoga book est vraiment
intéressant pour plusieurs choses
la toute première chose qui est
intéressante sur cet objet look de
lenovo c'est le multi mode c'est à dire
qu'on peut l'utiliser de différentes
manières et ça c'est vraiment
intéressant
il y en a en tout 4 4 si vous en trouvez
d'autres huis clos - commentaire parce
que pour l'instant je n'en connais que 4
la toute première vous l'ouvrez
complètement vouloir tourner et ça vous
fait une tablette que vous allez pouvoir
utiliser à la verticale ou alors à
l'horizontale
bon jusque là vous apprends rien c'est
une tablette somme toute assez classique
il existe deux versions soit une version
android soit une version windows 10 moi
personnellement je laisse aux windows
disent on va pouvoir
deuxièmement l'utiliser en mode tablette
mais cette fois ci au louvre ont
légèrement ce qui vous permet
effectivement de la reposer l'a posée
sur un socle est de pouvoir après
regarder des choses que ce soit des
séries que ce soit différentes choses
vous pouvez aussi utiliser comme cette
sueur en pianotant en faisant des
actions différentes actions su ça marche
extrêmement bien
le deuxième mode est un peu un parallèle
une évolution du premier mode puisque il
s'agit juste de l'ouvrir et de la faire
reposer le troisième mode on arrive sur
un mode ordinateur un peu plus classique
vous allez l'apprendre vous la mettez
dans cette position là et ça vous fait
un petit ordi tout simplement le clavier
en dessous le clavier de yoga bout qui
s'appelle le clavier à l'eau alors le
clavier à l'eau est quand même plutôt
plutôt bien pensées sont toutes des
touches virtuelles
il n'y a pas de touches réel dessus vous
pouvez néanmoins pianoter dessus vous
allez avoir un retour de la touche qui
va faire qu'on espèce de petite
digression doigt c'est pas
nécessairement très très agréable ça on
peut le supprimer en rentrant dans les
paramètres de
à de la tablette heureusement et après
effectivement un bruit pour vous
indiquer lorsque vous tapez
personnellement j'ai supprimé bruits et
vibrations je trouve que c'est pas
terrible terrible par contre en terme de
sensations de prise en main pour taper
dessus et pourrait effectivement avoir
des sensations ordinateur c'est plutôt
bien la seule chose que je regrette que
je reprocherais effectivement sur ce
mode là savoir un clavier qui est un peu
plus petit ce qui fait qu'il faut le
temps de prendre ses marques pour savoir
positionner ses doigts et pouvoir
utiliser correctement mais sinon après
dans ce mode là je dirais le mode
ordinateur votre ordinateur qu'on peut
déplacer partout c'est vraiment bien
fait c'est plutôt bien pensée très
agréable alors effectivement on a un
petit écran on n'est pas sur un 13
pouces ou un castres où sont nés sur un
10 pouces point ans avec une résolution
de 1920 par 1200 le quatrième mode est à
mon avis le mode qui est vraiment le
mode spécifique à l'ail aux gars book
c'est à dire que vous allez prendre
votre gars book vous l'ouvrez de cette
manière là et vous allez l'utiliser pour
pouvoir dessiner dessus alors vous avez
plusieurs possibilités
vous avez un style et le style eryl
peine vous avez soit la solution de
mettre une mine auquel cas vous allez
utiliser le carnet de notes que vous
allez poser sans voiture gay book et
vous allez pouvoir dessiner écrire et
faire un pas mal de choses dessus la
possibilité suivante c'est de mettre une
mine qui n'a pas d'encre qui
effectivement inclus directement avec
votre stylet et là vous allez pouvoir
dessiner directement sur
la zone dédiée sur notre guide book ce
qui vous permettra de pouvoir prendre
des notes de pouvoir dessiner ça vous
sert en réalité deux tablettes
graphiques et c'est vraiment ça la
particularité c'est un gars book faut
savoir que c'est quand même un produit
qui est plutôt destiné aux graphistes
aux infographistes qu'on peut aussi
utiliser pour un usage professionnel
la prise de notes rapides tout ce genre
de choses là c'est vraiment extrêmement
pratique moi qui ne suis pas graphiste
j'ai beaucoup de plaisir à l'utiliser
or je vais pas me mettre à dessiner
demain je suis toutefois seront chères
si j'avais eu un talent dans ce domaine
ça se saurait depuis bien longtemps mais
pour l'utilisation professionnelle je
dois reconnaître que l'outil est
pratique parce qu'il est petit il est
compact on le met dans un sac qui on
l'emmène partout avec soi mais ça on en
reparlera très très prochainement dans
une prochaine vidéo même si c'est un
gars book présente quatre modes pour moi
il y en a réellement 3 la première je
vous le disais c'est le mode tablette
toutes fermées ou légèrement ouverte
le deuxième on est sur un ordinateur
portable avec un vrai clavier le clavier
à l'eau qui fonctionne très bien et un
trackpad et la dernière possibilité
c'est effectivement la possibilité de
pouvoir utiliser la tablette graphique
avec le stylet que ce soit pour faire du
dessin pour la prise de notes
voilà un petit peu l'étendue des
possibilités que l'on peut faire avec
sept chiots gars book
dites moi ce que vous en pensez en
commentaire est ce que vous pensez que
cet outil est intéressant ce qu'il
pourrait vous intéresser si oui pour
quelle utilisation
mark et moi tout ça on frappe plein
d'autres d'autres vidéos sur le yoga
boukili a pas mal de choses à dire
dessus notamment tout ce qui va être
l'utilisation de la tablette graphique
on va rentrer dans le détail
et justement pour moi c'est un côté un
petit peu initiatique surtout que je ne
suis pas du tout raciste
donc ça va être plutôt sympa on parlera
aussi de la mobilité on parlera de plein
plein de choses dont je vous invite à
rester connectés sur la chaîne à vous
abonner si le contenu vous plaît puis
pourquoi pas me laisser un joli pouce si
le contenu de la vidéo vous a intéressé
merci beaucoup d'avoir regardé et pour
ma part je vous dis à très bientôt
au revoir
paris
[Musique]